tu es rentré quand à 17 heures quand je
t'ai envoyé le message encore compter
une croix dessinée sur ta main ça c'est
mes mots techniques
tu connais pas généralement tu fais une
croix pour te souvenir tu dois te
rappelle quelque chose c'est absurde
ça sert à rien de te rappeler que tu te
souvenir de quelque chose si tu sais pas
quoi mais je suis pas con c'est pour ça
que pour moi la croix ça veut toujours
dire la même chose c'est-à-dire la croix
sur l'île regard dans ta main d une
flèche qui te montres ton avant bras
gauche de gauche ah oui boîte aux
lettres la boîte aux lettres c'est pas
un peu long pour juste soutenir d'aller
poster m posté le net ça rien à voir la
boîte aux lettres de crédit relevait à
deux horaires différents 16 heures en
semaine et 12 heures le samedi 16 cp et
12 cl premier loft ma première histoire
de tatouages que j'ai sur la jambe par
gates oui mais marguerite c'est aussi
une pizza la pizza c'est l'italie
l'italie c'est l'europe et l'europe
c'est l'euro l'euro c'est l'argent
l'argent c'est sur mon compte
mon compte c'est sur ma carte bleue qui
est dans mon porte monnaie à cauet sur
ta carte bleue
voyez les picards incarcés les surgelés
les surgelés et faux dangers manger
faire les courses pour toi ses courses
et comment tu fais pour te rappeler de
ce que tu dois acheter
je fais des listes comme tout le monde
[Musique]